so how's it going to work chuck please
okay you don't have to get up fool shut
up man
you you have a laser that's the point of
a laser
he doesn't have no idea okay get in
front of that and ruin the shot
but go ahead we got it america okay
loser loser so here's what's going to
happen loser
you're not explaining the fact i'm
explaining it these two teams are losers
right the two losers are gonna play each
other
the two half losers gonna play which one
should we watch the pointer or your
finger so
okay so what happens in that 9-10 game
well though the
the two top losers move over here
they're not the top losers actually
they are first nine they're the first
they have
okay so what happens though they play
each other and the winner gets all moved
over here and
what happens the other one well then the
two baby losers
seven and eight they they play over here
yo put the put the laser down you know
okay
where's the winner going the winner goes
right over here to the seven seat over
here
okay and these two losers gonna play the
number one seed then they'll be
losered out after the first round of the
playoffs
and then i have a feeling it's going to
be the same thing on the other side only
in red
these are the two losers these are nine
and ten america
okay and these are seven eight so with
nine beats ten what happens
uh they play the winner no this what
happens with
if nine they play the loser or cell mate
they play the second loser
okay okay and then that the the winner
plays the hc the first loser they're
gonna get killed
okay then the second loser goes down
here to number seven you know what this
sounds like
first time somebody was explaining
crypto coins to me hey hey look
you know what they thought crypto coins
i
i don't believe in crypto coins i'm just
saying you better believe but i'm just
saying
jack you believe in crypto coin nah okay
what about you ernie what about uh
i